[الموسيقى]
لعقود من الزمن ، كانت الرياح والطاقة الشمسية
محور الطاقة الخضراء ، لكن
الأمواج والمد والجزر المستمرة للمحيط
غنية أيضًا بالطاقة المتجددة التي
ظلت غير مستغلة إلى حد كبير
قبالة سواحل الطاقة البحرية المدارية في اسكتلندا ،
وهي واحدة من الشركات التي تحاول
التغيير  أن المنصة العائمة بحجم نفاثة ضخمة
تسمى o2 بها دوَّاران عملاقان
يجلسان على ارتفاع 60 قدمًا تحت
سطح الماء ويمكنهما تسخير
طاقة المد والجزر في المحيط ، إنها الطاقة الحركية ،
لذا فإن أجزاء التكنولوجيا التي
تولد الطاقة لا تبدو
مختلفة جدًا عن  توربينات الرياح ولكن على عكس
توربينات الرياح التي يجب أن
تستوعب الرياح القادمة من جميع الاتجاهات ، فإن
o2 يحتاج فقط إلى التقاط الطاقة من اثنين
لديك نوع من الفيضانات ويأتي المد
والجزر لديك وقت هوائي
ويخرج المد والجزر بعيد  أكثر موثوقية
من الرياح ، يمكنك التنبؤ بهذه الحركات
قبل سنوات وعقود من التقدم ،
وهذا هو نظام التوربينات المدارية الثالث المداري
ليتم توصيله
بالشبكة الوطنية للمملكة المتحدة  أو الاختبار منذ عام 2012.
يتميز هذا التصميم الأخير بالدوارات التي
يمكن أن ترفع من الماء لتسهيل
الوصول للإصلاحات ، وتقول الشركة إن 102
وحدة تولد ما يصل إلى 2 ميغاواط والتي
تقول إنها كافية لتشغيل حوالي 2000
منزل سنويًا
.  القيام به في
جزيرة روزفلت في مدينة نيويورك هو
ما فعله الأخوان رايت في كيتي
هوك
في نظام ثلاثي الإطارات التابع لسلطة الطاقة الخضراء في الولايات المتحدة
والذي يعمل في الجزء السفلي من
النهر الشرقي وهو في الواقع عنوان
مستقيم إنه في مرحلة ما قبل التجارة
ولكنه يسلم بنشاط  الطاقة
لشبكة الكهرباء في مدينة نيويورك ، فإن إمكانات
الطاقة البحرية آه هي ما
يقرب من 250 جيجاوات حول العالم وهذا
المد والجزر فقط لا يشمل الأنهار أو
القنوات الكبيرة حتى تتمكن من رؤية
إمكانات التطبيقات ليس فقط
تقنيتنا ولكن منافسينا مثل
حسنًا ، أعني أن هناك متسعًا كبيرًا
ونأمل حقًا أن ينجح منافسونا أيضًا
من أجل الصناعة ولكن
علينا خفض تكاليفنا
الآن التكلفة العالية  من بناء
وتشغيل وصيانة تكنولوجيا طاقة المد والجزر
يعني أن طاقة المد والجزر تأتي
بعلاوة ولكن الاستثمار الحكومي
يمكن أن يلعب دورًا حيويًا في دفع
السعر إلى الانخفاض
في المملكة المتحدة ، وهناك حوافز اقتصادية
نعتمد عليها في
مشاريعنا التجارية الأولى حيث أننا  بدء
الإنتاج الضخم للتكنولوجيا التي سنقوم
بتحريكها من المملكة المتحدة والعودة إلى
أمريكا الشمالية ، ألاسكا ، نيويورك ، كندا ،
التيارات المائية الهائلة في كل مكان
لحصاد
البحار المحولة والمدارية ، ما هي إلا
شركتان من العديد من الشركات التي تطور
طرقًا للاستفادة من المحيط
غير المستغل  الموارد
بينما يقارن بعض الخبراء طاقة المد والجزر
بما كانت عليه طاقة الرياح قبل 20 عامًا ،
إنها مسألة وقت فقط قبل
أن تلعب محيطاتنا دورًا أكبر
لن يتم حل مشكلة تغير المناخ من خلال
حل واحد إذا أضفتها جميعًا معًا ، بدأنا في
صنع  فرق كبير وهذا
ما نحتاجه
[موسيقى]